I think yes there is a way that society
looks at quote unquote black America or
black Americans it's just this one thing
I don't think there is enough
understanding of how diverse black
America actually is you know I could
list a number of incidents that would
suggest you know that it's it's the same
way that people actually treat Africa
you know to a certain extent people just
like Africa is this one thing so if
you're from Nigeria then you're the same
as somebody from Kenya not realizing
that within Nigeria right we have 250
different ethnic groups right 250
different languages and it's the same
here in the United States I mean okay so
everybody speaks English but being black
American isn't the same thing for
everybody and I think the fact that that
doesn't get as much plane that doesn't
get acknowledged as much in this society
is to the detriment of both black
Americans and the society as a whole so
I think I mean I think that definition
needs to be changed I think that
attitude and idea needs more needs to be
blown open a bit more needs to be
explored and I think you see it
happening more and more of these days
but I still think there is this general
attitude that oh it's just this set of
people it's this something like and they
all behave the same they all act the
same they all you know and things have
changed and are changing or getting
better but I think there's still that
attitude that needs to be attacked and
blown open
I really don't like questions like that
but I I mean because I would experience
I would describe my experience in the
States as a person before anything else
a person who happens to be these
different things and so I know I don't
know that there's actually an answer to
that question that would be fulfilling
so then I'm just going to skip it
you